next prototype driverless cars are
appearing on the high streets your watch
can tell you how healthy you are and the
days of using your mobile phone just to
make calls are over welcome to the so
called Internet of Things Kevin Ashton
is the godfather of this movement he
coined that term and the refined the
process of how our machines communicate
well how to fly a horse is the unlikely
title of his book about how the creative
process is more about perspiration than
inspiration I met him earlier this week
and began by asking where the creativity
should come easily to us all oh well I
wouldn't say was easy but I do think
it's donate and we will have the ability
to be perhaps more creative than we
realize but we've been we've been fed a
bit of a live the last hundred years or
so which is that you have to be some
kind of genius and ideas will suddenly
pop into your head at unexpected moments
and all you have to do is write them
down and you'll be good to go and none
of those things are true actually you
start with a problem and you try and
solve it and your first attempt probably
won't be good but if you keep going
eventually you'll get there this
collaboration help or hinder that
depends I think what we see when we look
at people who are successful and they
collaborate they tend to come together
when they they have a problem they don't
quite know how to solve or perhaps
they're feeling a little bit down and
they need cheering up and then they'll
kind of go back to their their study or
their office and and do a little bit
more creative work so if you come
together once in a while to sort of pep
each other up or maybe help solve a
difficult problem then that's very
helpful what's challenging is when you
have 25 people in a room all trying to
work together simultaneously so is there
actually an original idea or do all of
us even the gifted ones steal the odd
thought and maybe just change it a
little to come up with something new
everything new is made of something old
but you know the
where you make it new is you you add a
just in a pinch of something different
and that's how everything gets created
there really when we we look at the
stories of pretty much everything that's
been created and invented you find that
it's a series of very small steps and
even the people who are most famous for
inventing something have have really
built on the work of other people is it
necessary to fail to get good at being
creative yes you know you do a first
draft in a second draft and the third
draft or a prototype that doesn't work
you know sir james dyson did 5126
prototypes of his vacuum cleaner before
he had one that worked so it's essential
to be ready to fail but you have to
survive the failure you know you can't
you do it do the thing and it explodes
and you die then obviously that's that's
not good do you think culturally we're
ready for that failure though that we
have a fear of it and therefore we might
shy away therefore you might not try and
push that idea at all absolutely and
that's a side effect of this this myth
about you know genius is having ideas in
their sleep and only having to write
them down when you sit down to create
anything for the first time even if
you're very experienced you know your
first attempt is not going to be that
good but that's the beginning and then
you make the second attempt you make
things a little better and you keep
going for as long as it takes and
eventually those steps lead you to to
somewhere extraordinary how do you fly a
horse one bite at a time know that the
title is there actually a quotation from
wilbur wright of the wright brothers who
explained how it was that they were the
first people to fly by pointing out that
the problem of flying is actually not
getting into the air it's balancing your
aircraft when you stay in the air and he
dropped a piece of paper to the ground
and it would you know dart backwards and
forwards and he said you know this is
the horse we must learn to ride if we
want to fly Kevin Ashton thank you very
much indeed